okay I think we are live on the David
Pakman show
YouTube channel I have Tim Poole with me
who hopefully we are also live on your
platform soon Tim how are things looking
over there not good it's not working
it's not we're okay well we'll we'll let
we'll give Tim a second to get to get
things rolling I'll just welcome
everybody on my youtube channel we're
going to be talking about a whole bunch
of different stuff including platforming
censorship free speech it's gonna be
quite a list and if people aren't
familiar with Tim maybe we'll get to
know him in a little bit Tim is working
on getting us going on his channel as
well I'm just trying to do a new stream
I guess all right you can sorry yeah no
problem
so for people I mean it kind of works
out okay because people are will give
people time to get in get in here we
have a whole bunch of new clips
scheduled to go live on the david pakman
show YouTube channel for the rest of the
day I think there's going to be some
good stuff in there that people will
like many people liking the David Pakman
off of social media topic and I followed
up on that on today's program there's a
clip that I think goes live at maybe
10:30 p.m. Eastern related to that and
if there's anything that's like ever
unified my audience across left and
right it's me saying I might get off a
social media left and right absolutely
loving that the typing you here is Tim
Poole who's our yes now no problem Tim
where he is getting himself all good to
go so that we can have a conversation on
both of our channels and setting up a
new stream and all of that stuff is it
how would you rate it how is it going to
in like between 1 and 10 it's going
really bad I have no idea why it's
giving me the business yeah it's not
it's not I don't know if it's working
and are you trying to get Moby yes yeah
yep
alright and so you've got your you've
got your YouTube stream address from
your go live dashboard and the stream
key yeah and it's just I think we're
live our live it's working okay I just
have to I have to post the link okay no
problem so Tim I a second to do that
well yeah yeah you know say what you
want to say about
whatever while I well I was going to go
into an anti-semitic screed but I want
to make sure you hear all of it I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna wait a second okay
so we're gonna be having a conversation
with Tim Poole Tim Poole is known to
some people in my audience and not known
to some people in my audience so maybe
we could potentially start there
so I guess Tim to begin with like what
what are we doing how is how did this
all happen and why why are we even
talking today it's because we had sort
of like a Twitter I don't even know if
it's a disagreement but we had a
conversation on Twitter that led to this
conversation yes so I posted a tweet
where I said I can't really remember but
something about why should social media
companies be exempt from civil rights
law right and then you responded with I
think this is a good-faith attempt but a
bad take right I responded I don't know
exactly what the thread was but it was
essentially for me the issue comes about
for one with the constant talk of
censorship on social media and the idea
that you know these platforms have
become so powerful they're actually
influencing elections yeah so we
shouldn't let private companies just do
whatever they want but specifically
there was a story from motherboard where
the head the lead of the story kind of
buried an important issue it said that
Twitter won't use an algorithm to remove
white nationalists because it might get
Republicans right in the story it said
Twitter believes not only do they
believe it's acceptable but then the
public finds it acceptable finds it
acceptable that innocent Muslims are
removed from Twitter because they're
trying to get Isis I personally find
that unacceptable but they find it
unacceptable that Republicans would be
sort of caught up in a similar
application of a policy to remove white
nationalists in other words it's not an
equal application you're saying yes so
we ended up seeing this wave of stories
where they said you know incorrectly
Twitter won't ban white nationalists
well the story was specifically that
because white nationalists use Trump
rhetoric if they implemented an
algorithm it would sweep up innocent
Republicans and Twitter said the it was
it was one Twitter employee I might add
because Twitter's denying this but the
employee said the public wouldn't accept
that so we're not gonna do it and mocha
so that's their opinion so to speak it
was yeah
one employee and I think we should be
careful about stuff like that but if
this one employee is to be taken at face
value he straight-up said that Arab
language broadcasters and Muslims will
get banned arbitrarily by algorithm I
don't think that's really maybe
incorrectly I mean other words there
will be false positives I guess there's
maybe a more accurate way to say it sure
right right you know simply because some
people in Isis use similar language to
regular Muslims it's going to negatively
impact everybody and so the I guess the
point I was trying to make is under
Section under the broad interpretation
of section 230 and using additionally a
First Amendment argument social media
companies online services are exempt
from civil rights law III mean that it's
it's it sounds as bad as it is it's
mind-blowing to me okay so let's let's
work up to that if we can so let and
even I mean maybe just to set the stage
and then in a second we'll get to what
parts we do agree on and then maybe
that'll help us figure out where we
might disagree if people don't know you
like what are your politics how should
people be sort of thinking about your
politics in the context of this
conversation
um I guess no one believes me but that's
okay I think I've always been kind of a
social liberal I was a I was a fervent
Bernie supporter in 2016 but I have
definitely moved a little way for Bernie
for several reasons uh right now I am
currently supporting and have donated to
Tulsi Gabbard and Andrew yang but I am
very very anti Democratic establishment
mhm and admittedly I am NOT like when it
comes to I think for your audience I've
made maybe like two to five percent of
my videos directly at trump and about
what Trump has done okay I do I do
regularly say bad things about Trump but
I think my focus is very much on what I
see is the Democrats are moving in a
dangerous direction not that I think the
corporate centrist types like Biden and
Hillary are any good right but I I'm
seeing what I feel culturally is a
dangerous progression on the left
towards regressive authoritarian there's
the there's the tribal word regressive
and so I'm very much focused on how the
media manipulates how but you know I
don't wanna get too much into that I
suppose my politics are rather
center-left
a lot of ways and I out there's two
reasons why I'm actively supporting
Tulsi and Andrew yang okay for one
Wow yang I got it I got admit when I
first started watching him I was kind of
like whatever you know I don't like ubi
but the dude really has thought out a
lot and I agree with so much of what
he's doing just go to his website he's
got a ridiculous amount of policy ideas
and the way he's framing ubi
actually as a VAT tax dividend through
these massive corporations that spoke to
me a lot because one of the biggest
issues I have is these tech monopolies
it is it literally we're gonna be
talking about yeah out there they're
taking over the Commons well let's not
jump the gun on that but so okay my if
if my observation is that it's you're
right it seems about two to five percent
of your channel is criticizing Trump I
just took a glance at it before we went
live 85% of it seems to be criticizing
not just Democrats but the left so I
want to help you defend your position
that you are center-left because like if
somebody looks at my channel it's
obvious that I'm on the left and I'm a
progressive if you look at just my last
ten videos my last 20 videos my last
hundred videos whatever when I pulled up
your channel I see
Republicans push laws to end censorship
Pro Republicans story
Facebook's purge of the rise that begun
is that pro Republican I think it I mean
well so let me get to that in a second
let me explain it so I'll get so
conservative news added to blacklist
conservatives are the victims leftist
activists not establishment Dems
but leftist activists force MasterCard
to vote on banning the far right the far
right is the victim and Tifa planned
armed disruption of US border it's the
left that's causing violent chaos at the
border censorship backfires on far left
of course far left is not establishment
Dems another hate crime hoax exposed
that's real I mean the hate crime hey
that's less politically overtly
political molar report provides media a
proves media is a fake news trash fire
mostly a story being parodied by the
right although there are enclaves on the
Left that are saying that so my view Tim
is and you know we've known each other
for years and this not this is just my
assessment of what's on your channel
that about 85% of your content is going
after the left and I totally get
criticizing the left from the left like
I do that as well but the the
overall selection is selection of
stories that to me seems as painting the
right in a good light or as the victims
and choosing to go after relatively
insignificant enclaves of the left tell
me I'm wrong
well no I'd you know you the way you see
it is the way a lot of people see it I
think you have your opinion your view I
can psychoanalyze myself for a second
and I think for me I was kind of you
know growing up kind of ostracized by a
lot of the establishment and main left
but more specifically again to
psychoanalyze myself I I went through
I've gone through a period where all of
the attacks I receive and everything
that tries to ruin my life is coming
from this one group of left-wing
individuals for a specific purpose and
that's naturally going to result in
certain behaviors and certain focuses so
it's actually you know I want to make it
seem like a cop-out you know I've been
physically attacked by the left not the
right
I've been I've been people are right now
taking a quote from voxcom to make it
seem like I am an anti-semite so they
can get me removed from my bank account
and stuff that's not coming from
conservatives it never has that's even
one that's totally up there but I guess
well I mean I will go through these
videos that I will show so yeah I
forgive me and I actually don't need you
to do an accounting of each video but
for me it's more if I look at your
channel and 85% is criticisms that are
what I would consider relatively niche
in terms of their existence on the left
it doesn't strike me as someone whose
priorities are Center left to say well
know what I think 85% of my channel
should be but here's the thing
Elsie Gabbard denounced identity
politics outright with Michael Tracy she
said straight up it's divisive it's bad
for us okay identitarian ism is one of
the biggest things that I have a problem
with due to my my hit my family history
being like I know it's kind of a meme
but mixed and this comes from when we
look at affirmative isn't that identity
politics you're saying your view on this
is informed you're against identity
politics as informed by your identity
yeah it is what it is I'll put it this
way I am not permitted a left nor the
right allow me an identity so what that
does is it kind of ostracized me and
what I find recluse it not recluse but
what I find
safe-harbor I guess is the fact that the
u.s. actually had protections against
discrimination based on race in these
things so for me someone who's
experienced it from both directions I'm
apprehensive towards either direction
when I have the left telling him a white
male on the right telling me I'm a
mudblood fine but Tim so so I have the I
have the left saying I'm not Jewish I'm
white and I have white privilege and I
have the right saying I'm not white I'm
Jewish and Jews are a race that is
really bad
and we should be really so the fact but
that doesn't make me all of a sudden say
I'm gonna do 85 percent of my videos and
criticize the left you know what I mean
no I think it's what you personally find
important right you know if you watch
any of my videos like so here's a thing
yeah subject matter doesn't dictate
politics simply because you've got you
know who's and again it's my opinion but
when I say who's trying to remove people
from the internet it's not it's not like
Nancy Pelosi it's a particular sect of a
group of progressive more far-left
individuals who's trying to get people
removed from their banks who's trying to
get people banned who's arguing in favor
of regulation that restricts speech it's
not conservatives and it's not moderate
Democrats okay but allies don't really
specifically to that issue but let's not
be labor it I do find it sort of
interesting though that in the same
sentence that you said you're against
identity politics and that's why you
like Tulsi you made an identity politics
argument based on your identity which
strikes me as a contradiction of sorts
that's that well there that was weird to
me there's the support of politics based
on someone's identity and the support of
a Pope like our opposition to that right
I don't
the and and let me make clear some
identity politics are absolutely a good
thing
it's identitarian ism that's a bad thing
so okay I made us so I tell people this
Authority is a good thing like when a
doctor tells you hey there's someone
injured put your hand on the wound
that's true Authority you'll just do it
you know they're right okay but
authoritarianism is a really really bad
thing so telling telling someone in our
society you cannot factor in race in in
terms of public accommodation that's a
violation of civil rights I like that
when you say we're absolutely going to
factor in race I don't like that so it
is it's nuanced I guess right
and does anyone who's saying that we
have to factor in race when it's not a
relevation the ACLU when they supported
affirmative action at Harvard which
lumps all Asians Indian Chinese Laotians
into one category and I find that
offensive as an Asian person and so when
I come out and say Tim claim that's an
identity to say you should be able to
argue whether it's offensive or not
offensive right or not right without
saying because you are part Asian you
fight like that's identity politics
which you claim to be against I know I
agree and I think I think the
clarification then I think what we're
discovering here is that it's not so
much the core idea of identity politics
it's the application of in ways that
either is reductive or authoritarian so
let me frame it this way the civil
rights movement paramount 100 percent
important it's the only reason my family
was able to live in this country without
threat of law because miscegenation laws
made it illegal for my family to live
together
it was identity politics that ended that
but that was the end of identitarian ism
where they actually said this this for
this race this for that race and so we
implemented laws that said you can't do
X based on these characteristics I like
that it's not perfect but now we're
seeing particularly again I think it's
Harvard where there's there's a really
common idea of all all race is one thing
and that's just not true right so
there's a reportedly separate from
identity politics so I think we're
clarifying the issue in that case that
okay right so if I I think to reduce it
to simply identity politics is more of a
tribal signifier like if I say to
certain people identity politics they
not and they understand and I think I
think what you're bringing up it's
actually really important because we're
seeing how you language kind of divides
us more well bring it up all I'm
bringing up is that twice now you're in
in the in the context of saying you're
against identity politics you brought up
your identity as the basis for why you
feel the way you do which seems to me
like identity politics and so I guess to
clarify I think it's wrong to judge
people based on the color of their skin
and we should judge them based on the
content of their character okay so to me
to my interpretation of identitarian ism
based on its root definition as identity
based government would be the government
saying this for this race that for that
race that to me is wrong
so when you when you see like certain
groups advocating that we should factor
in race for college admissions I think
that's wrong I think we should judge
individuals based on who they are and
and one of the reasons for this is that
it doesn't matter what what your skin
color is it doesn't matter if you're gay
straight trans or whatever you can be
rich or poor and if we start acting like
the true signifier of someone's prosper
someone's you know capabilities or
someone's privilege is what color their
skin is that's that's when things are
evolving into overt racism because
you're gonna have particularly wealthy
wealthy say Indians millionaire high
caste individuals who come to America
and claim that the the middle-class
working family who's white has more
power than they do and this argument
starts getting it's dangerous yeah we
want to take what we can find counter
examples where the more prominent
historical narratives aren't true but I
think we need something stronger to make
to make a sort of broader indictment of
what policy might be but because we're
so we're kind of now getting into what
we were originally going to talk about
so let's let's explore part one of
censorship and and discrimination etc
there are identity elements that are
protected classes under the law some of
them are protected under the 1964 Civil
Rights Act so I believe going from
memory race is protected under the 64
Civil Rights Act I believe nationality
is comes from the 1964 Civil Rights Act
and some others there are others like
for example age age is a protected class
on the basis of the employment
discrimination Act of 1967 the exact
origin of each category doesn't matter
so much as the point that this is what
the law currently says is that something
you are in agreement with or do you
think those laws are problematic civil
rights protections yes on the base of
the categories I listed I don't want to
be reductive but I would say at first
glance absolutely civil rights expanding
them even I think like the Equality Act
for instance important but you know I
often bring up the caveats that we have
to be careful about because we're trying
to protect everyone's rights and we have
to make sure we don't overlap in certain
areas like you know over at Christians
who believe that gay people should be
claiming that's their right when it
doesn't interfere with their lives it's
it's you know so that's not an argument
no it's not but what I mean is you
believe that it should be that employees
and biz and businesses should not be
able to discriminate against employees
and customers on the basis of the
religion for example or other statuses
veterans or race or whatever
well status as veterans I'm not I don't
know enough about well I didn't get into
that so I was going to ask you are there
any categories of protected class that
you actually don't think should have
protected status I don't know okay
I mean I there's two that for me are
question marks and I'll tell you why one
is religion and I go back and forth on
it for the following reason on the one
hand we have a country where freedom of
and freedom from religion is a very
important characteristic of how the
country was established so to say
religious belief or lack of religious
belief should not be protected
it seems problematic to me in in some
ways on the other hand religion is self
professed now you can say if you're born
into a Catholic family to choose not to
be Catholic anymore is different than to
be born agnostic and to choose to
continue being agnostic but religion is
self professed and on that basis I do
have a question mark around whether
religion should or shouldn't be a
protected class I don't have the answer
I think it should be you know and yeah
and and partly because it's law its
long-standing from the foundation of the
country right the idea of I don't know
how far back it goes but the idea that
you could you could come here and be
safe to believe what you believe and
live there is a challenge though because
what's what's to say I think someone
actually did this they tried claiming
that trumpism was a religion and they
believed Trump was the Messiah and a
judge told them no well so if it's a
cartoonish thing but you first do you
think it should be because that's the
way it's been for a long time that's an
argument or us to continuing to do
things because it's the way we've done
them I mean what people used to be
slowly yeah right so the idea with
religion is that we've create a society
where we have numerous religions right
and we've we've created an umbrella over
all of them saying you can't do these
things but you can participate in public
if you believe something
and so you quite you know for the
longest time we've had Christians who
believe you know Biblical Stone Age the
ideas and contradictory ideas the same
is true for Islam Judaism and many many
other religions I'm just calling out
Abraham specifically because that's the
easiest one to point to well we need to
live together we can't go to Muslims and
tell them you're not allowed to believe
us anymore but we can say the practice
of doing X based on the Quran or the
Bible is against the law so we do
restrict certain practices if it's a
violation of the law so yeah those are
called surprises and then it doesn't
matter sort of why you're doing it if
something's a crime it's a crime I guess
my question is if you say I am part of
the Pentecostal religion the that's a
sort of self professed choice and to me
it's much closer to being someone who
skateboards than it is to being someone
who's Asian so for me religion as a sort
of choice that people make is closer to
other choices that people make and it's
not an immutable characteristic so I
think if there was a case to be made
against protecting religion on that
basis it would be that it's just
something people choose I don't entirely
disagree I think that's a really good
point I I think my concern would be
would we remove the protection of
religion and then all of a sudden you
know bakery bakeries and whatever start
saying no to people and businesses start
restricting access to taxpaying
Americans so but let me do it let me do
this let me explain to you my rationale
for why the Baker in Colorado should
make the cake right okay we all pay
taxes if you want to argue we shouldn't
that's a different argument right now we
do that means my money goes towards the
roads it goes towards the plumbing it
glows toward the collective defense the
building you have where you sell goods
exist in a space I am contributing to
you if you weren't there someone else
could be it's not fair that I should
lose access to a portion of my community
because you don't like some immutable
characteristic about me now I think
there's a hard you figure out where the
line is gonna be challenging behavior
most likely if you go in start shrieking
top of your lungs then maybe they should
say you have to leave you're disturbing
people you're breaking the law but if
someone comes in wearing you know like
you know can a mom comes into a bakery
they should not be able to be like I'm
arbitrarily removing a member of the
public who contributes to my collective
defense to my fire services to my
plumbing
that's that you know so we need we need
social cohesion and we might not like
each other but we have to respect and
tolerate that we're all in this together
so it's a bit of a different I mean in
the only cap so I basically agree with
what you're saying I mean I don't think
that that that's something that should
happen religion is a protected class
precludes the necessity of the argument
you're making though doesn't it because
there's no it doesn't even matter
whether we think that for social
cohesion reasons it should or shouldn't
be allowed because religions already a
protected class yeah what do you
I guess I thought you're one beyond that
in a defense of why the how does this
relate more specifically to the baker
and the issue of of sexual orientation
it's a member of the public who's doing
something that is legal and has no in no
way impacts your business negatively
it's complicated I'll admit you know
it's you it's there's yeah things aren't
necessary black and white there's nuance
I mean I you know the question about
defining it that way is that there's
nothing illegal about saying we don't
serve people who we're Magga hats
political orientation is not a
politically impacted crap politically
but in fact in DC it is in Washington DC
it is okay which is outside of
Washington DC it's not a politically
it's not a protected class fashion
assuming that it is not inextricably
linked to religion which is a protected
class which would be like the mag aha
right that would be a fashion statement
that's not a protected class so I work
by your definition you also wouldn't be
able to ask someone to leave because of
their political affiliation which is
legal currently outside of Washington DC
is that something you would want to see
changed potentially and then it is
complicated so so I'll explain you know
if someone is believe something awful
and they're a taxpayer and they
participate in public I don't see what
your argument is to remove someone
arbitrarily from your business if
they're not doing anything you know it's
listen argument as private corporations
are simply allowed by the law you got to
change the law if you don't want them to
be able to do that they're little
they're allowed to kick anybody they
want out assuming they're not violating
assuming they're not doing it on the
basis of a protected class yeah that's
how it works right those signs that say
we sort of reserved you know we reserve
the right to refuse service to anybody
that's legally accurate assuming it's
not violating the protected class
non-discrimination laws so this is
actually a really really important thing
to break down so I think we get to the
line-drawing portion of your Bible
arguments exactly because I think we
both kind of we agree that people should
be protected but figuring out where and
how far I'm not entirely in favor of
protecting political classes like DC
does oh you're not I thought you just
said you were so the core concept of
letting a law-abiding calm decent person
like your average person go about their
business I like the idea but it is there
there has to be a line drawn somewhere
oh okay yeah I agree and right so so for
me I think the line is well I agree but
I think religion should be protected
what political political affiliation is
where things start to get questionable
to me okay right
um I'm not entirely against it I'm
interested in in entertaining the
concept I maybe lean towards it but it
is challenging and there's a lot of
questions that I think need to be broken
down to truly understand why or why not
and so ultimately I put it this way like
this conversation is part of the process
of figuring out where to draw the line
yeah yeah so I mean I guess it's like
right now it's not protected outside of
DC so if we want to go in the direction
of saying any potential I don't even
know the right words it's kind of
difficult I guess we're calling it a
potential or actual customer or or like
patron of a business one idea which
would be a significant move from where
we are now that you suggested is if the
person is doing something legal right if
they're just they're trying to buy a
cake for example or whatever the case
may be and it's a business that is open
to the public obviously there are
exceptions of businesses that simply
aren't open to the public which are sort
of handled differently if the person is
not breaking the law in some way a
business should not be allowed to turn
them away that would require some pretty
significant and heavy-handed government
intervention and private business would
it not Oh probably yeah yes and is that
philosophically based on your
self-described center-left politics is
that something you would be okay with
you know I think the challenge is having
the conversation and trying to figure
out what to do is different from being
like I would
like to assert the government do X you
know it's a challenge I honestly I don't
have all the answers what I do know is
we face up and I'm sorry if this is kind
of like dodgy of the question but you
can react and get my thoughts out yeah I
if we get to a point in society where we
start restricting access to businesses
you know things are to break down I
think it's I think even in terms of like
international endeavors an international
conflict we we want to have as many
links to each other as possible the more
trade we have in other countries the
less likely we are to engage in conflict
at least that's my general understanding
of a lot of you know history so it's a
challenge right if we said no religion
could you know we if we had no protected
classes
you see the story it was written about
by Wilt Chamberlain Lyndon Johnson would
send three of his staffers to drive from
DC to his home in Austin through the
south and they were all black and when
he one day he said will you take my dog
with you and they explained to him that
they drive for hours to try and find a
bathroom because they won't be allowed
to use these businesses so that's when
Lyndon Johnson was like oh my god this
is a bad thing yeah and I I agree so the
challenge is do like how far do we go
and trying to protect everybody do can't
we go too far and this is this is one of
the debates I think with everything
that's particularly the Equality Act
right now is why there's a lot of
contention around that who is worthy of
protection and who isn't for me I
honestly don't know my bigger issue and
I'll throw back to you to react anything
you think I may have missed yeah is that
social media platforms have men are
monopolizing the Commons in terms of
commerce financial transactions and
speech okay so let's get to the I want
to go to social media next but just to
make sure I understand your position on
this piece you said you you don't like
the idea of telling businesses that they
have to accept certain customers or
you're not in favor of changing the law
to make it so that businesses have to
accept certain customers if they don't
want to did I read that correctly well
let me try and clarify I think civil
civil rights law as it is today is is
fantastic okay um there's probably some
redundancies and some hiccups I'm not I
don't know all the laws I think we need
to have a conversation around civil
rights protections as important
to local and federal jurisdiction I
don't know if political affiliation
should be protected particularly because
there's a lot of crazy people out there
who believe crazy things who probably we
shouldn't allow in certain circumstances
but the same but you brought up a good
point about religion because religions
also believe crazy things so it's I
admit it's a it's a big challenge but at
the Business Regulation standpoint in
terms of the government coming in and
mandating favor of government coming and
putting the boot down on all of these
corporations that are destroying the
environment that are that are not paying
a dime in taxes that are putting their
money overseas that are generally
disrupting things and then pitting us
all against each other like I'm not
gonna want to rant but yes listen and
let me just bow and we're gonna move on
to social media but I want to be super
sure I understand this obviously
multinationals who don't pay taxes
that's more of a regulatory issue when
it comes to finances but imagine the the
customer walking into a clothing store
and the customer for whatever reason
that is not related to a protected class
the the store doesn't want to do
business with them should the government
say to the store you have to unless this
person's doing something illegal you
have to accept them as a customer or
should the business be allowed to say
please leave we don't want to serve you
I think that's too absolute it there's
there's too many factors it's nuanced I
would say there's no there's no yes or
no answer to that question right is the
person screaming is it do we not know
the whole point it's an act they're
doing they're not doing anything which
is criminal but they're also not being
asked to leave on the basis of a
protected class in which they are
members it's just the business doesn't
want to do business with them should a
private business have the right to say
we don't want to do business with you or
should the government force them to do
business now it depends on the scale
right if it's uh if it's small hole in
the wall that sells hotdogs and he says
you know what no hotdogs for you well
it's there it's a small hot dog shop if
it's something like The Electric Company
then probably not because you don't any
choices and so when a company gets too
big it dominates and so it's a really
nuanced question well right yes
utilities utilities I would argue are a
bit different from what we're talking
about here there let's say let's say the
the you know
a good way to put it there's only one
cable company right should cut Comcast
in the area where they own it refused
Internet service to certain people for
no reason I would say no most of those
companies would have a so I mean I I
think that that one is actually not
really a very important question because
most when Comcast comes in typically and
I was involved in the negotiation of
such a contract when I was on the board
of a TV station typically the contract
that Comcast signs with the municipality
says that they're not allowed to do that
so it actually would not really be an
issue
sounds like the government regulating
that right yeah absolutely
I'm not I am NOT a free-market I I
believe in the mixed economy I think you
need the government to come in and
correct errors and stuff like that okay
so if we if we note if we if we're
notified of an error or something going
wrong I think the government that's what
the government should be doing saying
like kind of like a referee
you know there's what I really do I
agree there yeah okay so let's talk
about social media a little bit so I did
a long piece about social media and
regulation as you know Town Square
public square sort of situation because
of the market share that some of these
social media platforms have have gained
and and you know maybe it goes beyond
just enforcing Terms of Service or maybe
it doesn't and what sort of best for the
individual what's best for society all
of this different stuff to get us into
that piece of it Tim my view
fundamentally is that private companies
have to be allowed to enforce Terms of
Service assuming that the enforcement of
those Terms of Service is not
discriminatory on the basis of the
protected classes that you and I just
spent 20 minutes talking about and I
guess mostly agree with that's my sister
they're exempt okay they're exempt
they'll not give me an stay or talk
about walk yes right no no I'm straight
up Twitter right now has the right to
ban all any protected class twitter can
say you know we're not gonna allow any
Asians on the platform but my my reading
of that of so I know that there's court
testimony that you tweeted which I
reviewed and I reviewed the context of
that and some legal opinions that's not
the opinion that I came away with the
opinion that I came away with is not and
let me see if I can I'll distinguish it
the way I understand
and then you tell me if I may be
misunderstanding it my reading of the
test and and this may be getting sort of
too in the weeds for some in the
audience maybe not but we'll give it a
shot my understanding of the testimony
that you linked me to is that it is not
that twitter could say as a policy we do
not allow Asian people on our platform
I've seen no serious legal opinion that
that is something Twitter would be able
to do my understanding is that if there
is a type of speech that Twitter
identifies that would disproportionately
rap up Asian people that that is
something Twitter is asserting would be
legally acceptable in terms of in in
terms of that particular testimony yeah
but as as we know from the motherboard
piece at least one employee said they
use an algorithm to sweep up Muslim his
target Isis which actually sweeps up
innocent Muslims but that's exactly the
point I'm making which is that's not
them Twitter is not saying as a policy
we don't allow Muslims they're saying we
have a policy to target Isis which is
mostly made up of Muslims which will
trigger some false positives so I guess
that the challenge then is are
reinforcing rules at a policy level or
an individual level if I agree we
completely that's that's actually that's
a key question but I don't want anybody
to think that what you're asserting
unless it is what you're asserting with
that yeah good so let's let's let's
let's dig into it um what is the Twitter
public accommodation that you can say
something and it will appear in reverse
chronological order to those who
subscribe to it right right that is the
public accommodation according to civil
rights law you cannot restrict a public
accommodation based on productive
characteristics if someone quotes a
verse from the Quran Twitter can remove
that okay so you're saying at the
individual level or through an algorithm
that is meant to identify okay they can
they know like Twitter a Twitter
employee has the First Amendment and
section 230 right to say anything
pertaining to this protected class we
can remove because Twitter is the thing
that so here's where I think and I don't
know if we're talking past each other or
if we actually disagree about what the
policy is or if we're just
misunderstanding what the policy is what
I'm saying is I have seen no evidence
nor any legal opinion nor have I seen
Twitter
say that they believe they could have a
policy that says we do not allow for
example Jews on Twitter and that would
be legal so yeah so let's try and great
to the real world okay the way you're
describing it would be that McDonald's
says no no you know Jews are allowed in
the store we just refuse to sell them
cheeseburgers you see I mean then what
the point of the winner not sure that
that's the phonology so let's check it
out Twitter is a platform where you can
express your thoughts okay you can go on
and you can otherwise what are you
really doing nothing like there's
literally that's all Twitter does
Twitter has a first amendment second and
section 230 argument where they say
whatever it is you say we can remove it
for any reason and the judge asked are
you saying you could remove someone even
if it would be discriminatory based on
religion or gender and the response from
Twitter's lawyers was yes right so that
the I I just think I think you're
misunderstanding that testimony and
there's a page that follows it or a
sequence that follows it that I think is
very illuminating I'll just give an
example and maybe the exam the analogy
will may allow us to move forward on
this imagine that Twitter wants to I
mean let's just take the one from from
we were talking about earlier Twitter
wants to enforce a ban on anti-semitic
content okay let's imagine that that's
something Twitter decided they were
going to do anti-semitic content on
Twitter is not equally balanced between
men and women we don't even have to
argue about what the split is but we
would just agree it's very unlikely that
it's 50/50 or fifty point three and
forty nine point seven the way that men
and women exist in society anti-semitic
content on Twitter is not evenly
balanced between right-wingers and left
wingers an ADL study says seventy one
percent is right-wing number doesn't
matter you might disagree with a number
but let's just imagine yeah it's not
evenly distributed what Twitter is
asserting is if indeed 71% of
anti-semitic content comes from
right-wingers we are going to be
disproportionately removing the content
of and banning conservatives or
right-wingers yeah whatever
you want to use not saying we would
legally be able to say no imagine that
they're white conservatives just for our
argument because we got to add a
protected class
Twitter's not saying if we wanted to ban
all white conservatives from Twitter we
would be allowed to do it that would
violate a very specific
non-discrimination law what they are
saying is that if the practice of
removing anti-semitic content
disproportionately targets people who
happen to be white as long as we're not
removing people for being white that is
legal and I agree that that's legal
that's a really interesting that's a
good point it's a really good point what
we're seeing now I think with the
digital space is that we've actually got
a distinction between people as thoughts
and the thoughts related to certain
characteristics and identities and the
individual themself and identity because
I think by your explanation and again I
think it's a good point
Twitter couldn't actually ban someone
for being gay because they're banning
the speech specifically right know like
if so well put this way yeah if someone
if someone was gay and made a post
talking about the things they do as a
gay person Twitter could ban them right
well I don't I mean I guess if they had
a policy that said what that you can't
talk about gay things I don't know no
I'm saying like from a legal from a
legal standpoint based on the the First
Amendment argument that Twitter is under
no obligation to support the speech of
anyone else right so if you're saying so
let's Twitter does have a policy that
bans hate speech which means because
like you said it's predominantly coming
from one side they predominately get
banned all right well and we're speaking
hypothetically out other numbers but but
for the sake we it's again I think it's
a good point you're it's something I and
realized there is going to be a
distinction between the individuals
identity and the ideas the ideas don't
have an identity right so are you are
you agreeing that you asserting that
Twitter claims they can ban people on
the basis of protected classes it was
not an accurate reading I think I think
you're correct but I do want to clarify
I think what we're actually seeing is
that there are certain ideas associated
with identity politics yes and that
twitter has the ability to remove ideas
around certain groups that are specific
to that group for instance I I agree
right right so this is a really great
distinction this is fantastic
Twitter's not going to say hey you're
Muslim you're gone like let's say a
Muslim guy says I'd like to order pizza
and they say ha you're Muslim you're
banned what they're actually saying is
the ideas associated with the Quran that
verse in particular we're going to
remove okay right and it will
disproportionately impact people who are
Muslim right yeah I think there's
another important distinction here which
is whether this is being done
algorithmically and people are being
caught up in false positives versus
whether Twitter is saying as a policy we
are going to proactively remove Quran
verses that relate to pizza or whatever
example you had I mean I think that's an
issue because when you go back to
Twitter said we have to be careful about
algorithmically removing white
nationalist content because like you
said a lot of Trump fists use similar
language and we're going to end up
removing trumpets who I mean I guess
aren't white supremacists I guess maybe
if they're using the language maybe they
are I don't know that the concern about
that that is an algorithmic
false-positive so that I think the
argument made by the Twitter employee
was that there a lot of white
nationalists will use like the Pepe meme
as well and they'll do like the ok hand
sign but a lot of Trump supporters will
use similar like you know I think Mogga
is the easiest way to put it
you absolutely are gonna have white
nationalists saying Maga for men if the
algorithm detects that overwhelmingly
people who talk about these issues also
have this hashtag we start grabbing
innocent people right that would be
interesting I think the more relevant
example is the opposite though because
so many people use Mogga
that it's very hard to imagine that
Twitter would execute a policy of
banning anyone who says Mogga
and it'll accidentally wrap up some
white nationalist I think a better
example Tim and tell me if you disagree
would be that there would be some kind
of phraseology that it's mostly white
nationalists using which some trumpets
that are my are not white nationalist
might use and it's the trumpets who
would accidentally get banned because
what you're describing would be a policy
that would actually be targeting Trump
aesthetics identify his Twitter saying
it would be the ICEA well it was um I
think it was was it James Wood James
Woods maybe who posted the the the
christchurch pepe clown world thing I'm
not sure I don't follow
James Woods found himself use a
yes an overt white nationalist meme and
I don't think he knew what it was so you
know I think that's that's that probably
is a good example they would have been
like get him out of there but it's you
know some of these things I don't know
you you you have an argument on the left
of whether or not the okay ham sign is
actually like a white supremacist hand
sign right but that's a relevant
argument when it comes to the legality
of what Twitter's asserting it can do
which i think is the more important
thing I mean yeah the left can debate
you know the right kind of eight the
right can debate whether referring to
money as shekels is in pleased
implicitly anti-semitic or not the Left
can debate whether the hand sign is or
is not but the more important thing to
me is I want to make sure that we're not
putting out false information about what
Twitter is asserting they could legally
do no I think I think you did a good job
when we kind of clarified that I think
you know a lot of a lot of these debates
come down to perspective right I'm
looking at a six you're looking at a
nine but I but I will say I think I
think it's fair to say what we've kind
of concluded is that Twitter isn't
banning someone for being a thing
they're banning for something for for
ideas pertaining to a thing right that's
my based on the testimony you sent me
that I read that's my I think you're
right I think you're right yeah so
that's why I guess my concern is yeah
should we protect the ideas pertaining
to being trans for instance I mean that
was gonna be my next question which is
okay given that we've established we had
sort of like part well part pre a of the
conversation was what are temples
politics but once we got past that we
got into what is our sense of protected
classes and non-discrimination law then
we got into what is it that we believe
Twitter can currently legally do and
what is Twitter seem to believe they can
currently do the next question is does
there need to be policy change and what
should that policy change be and doesn't
it get into the very overt government
intrusion into private businesses I
don't know the answer I guess we have to
start thinking about it I'm not I'm not
opposed to the government stepping in
when changes need to be made you know so
but what would we want the government to
do so this is a serious challenge that
has a lot of questions have to be
answered I don't know all the answers
what I do know is you have a large group
of people in the mainstream who believe
certain things and a large group of
people in the mainstream who believe the
opposite misgendering is the best
example now there's a lot of people who
think you know they tried
mischaracterize my argument that I'm
trying to argue in favor of people being
transphobic no absolutely not yeah I
could be clear to my audience let us
give Tim the full good-faith benefit
whether you believe he's earned it or
not and I'm not implying he has or
hasn't but it was this is his appearance
on my channel let's assume that his
argument is only what he claims it is
and not read more into it okay
ben shapiro has one of the top podcasts
in the world oh god he's a massive
following and his views are considered
to be mainstream I disagree with like
the good majority of his views but I
recognize that in order to bring about
sound policy in the direction I want we
have to champion over those ideas
through politics through debate well ben
shapiro believes that misgendering isn't
a thing that if someone is born
biologically male they're a he and if
someone is born biologically female
there as she cetera twitter has a rule
specifically that you can't do that you
I'm sorry that that you have to use the
pronoun someone requested so the most
notable instance would be Megan Murphy
and I'm not gonna get into for those
aren't familiar she did have some tweets
which talked about people specifically
but she had one tweet that was in
response to a night an argument about
the 1950s where she said men aren't
women though and she was suspended from
Twitter for that okay whether whether
you agree or disagree I think it's
important eyes the left believes respect
the pronoun and the right says don't
respect the personal pronouns if Twitter
has a policy in place that restricts
what you can or can't say it
disproportionately affects conservatives
who are engaging in a mainstream
perspective right how so I guess what I
would say is what we've discussed so far
in our conversation seems to be number
one we agree and it's not whether I see
a six and you see a nine we agree that
political class political orientation is
not a protected class that we we agree
with but this gets us into a bigger
question well we'll get to the bigger
question but let me handle it at the
micro first so the I would say no to
that it's not a protected class good no
no you think it is a protective
protective it is yeah and II see it is
which means well but out most people
don't live in DC right but it doesn't
matter should it should a national
company have to abide by local
jurisdictions for those jurisdictions I
think it would be
impossible standard for a company that
is a multinational company to be
expected to a by mean as a practical
matter it seems impossible to enforce or
expect something like that to be
informed they already do it they Twitter
already enforces per jurisdiction on the
basis of IP address I believe I believe
the answer is yes I don't know how they
enforced the laws of other countries
what they do and what if you have what
if you signed up for Twitter in DC but
are tweeting from Arizona which law gets
enforced probably Arizona I'd imagine
and is that basic but what's that but it
it this is this is one of the biggest
Civic challenges I think we're facing is
yeah these companies are in a digital
world you know so it's hard to know at
what level we can actually enforce these
things obviously it's it's it's true I
guess so the question then becomes one
of regulation right if Twitter's Terms
of Service are I mean okay let's take it
let's build it back so we started at the
top with an example and we're going down
let's just for a second as a thought
experiment reverse it and build it from
the bottom up can businesses exist that
have perspectives on how transgender
people are treated within their
businesses is that acceptable legally I
actually don't necessarily
I think the answer is yes yeah I think
the answer is yes I even I had asked
rhetorically I think I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry the answer is actually no in
many jurisdictions
yes exactly no what do you mean um
there's been a the the new the new human
rights laws that are emerging around
like in New York Philly New Jersey and
now with the Equality Act I don't know
specifically about the Equality Act but
I do know that at least in New York you
cannot take self expression into account
for how you have your business so what
ends up happening is there any new build
can't have a men's or women's room they
can't create special circumstances for
people based on their identity and
literally identity as a whole it could
be anything you could be a furry you
could be whatever so they're making
neutral bathrooms just single rooms with
no markings on them for everybody but
but let me let's see if we can maybe
boil it down to a specific example i
david pakman in Boston Massachusetts I
have a company I've got a hundred
employees and I've got an
handbook and my employee handbook says
here is the policy for time off here's
how you request vacation here is how
tardiness and absenteeism will be
handled and as a matter of policy we
refer to people with the gender pronouns
that they request would there be
anything legally problematic about that
I think the answer is no because it
actually falls under civil rights
protection but again I'm not I'm not a
lawyer I think but I will be able to
establish my business as long as I'm not
violating anyone's as long as I'm not
you know violating the seconds classes I
would be allowed what do that actually I
again I'm not a lawyer but I'd argue and
a First Amendment argument does the
answer is no you can't make someone
speak oh I'm not making anyone speak I'm
just saying that as a matter of company
policy we refer to people on the basis
of the pronoun that is associated with
their gender identity that I'm not
forcing anyone to say anything you can
sit there at your computer and write
emails and not talk to anybody have any
policy right I'm just saying that's the
person if you know if you don't enforce
it I mean it's actually a tough question
I'm not a lawyer I wouldn't I wouldn't
be able to answer like we're building to
though is at a certain point if it's not
if it's not violating someone's status
as a member of a protected class by by
intent as we already talked about intent
and an impact there's sort of two
different things I don't know
legally how we tell Twitter they can't
have a policy on how people should be
gendered I think it's an issue of
developing the Civic and figuring out
where we draw the line and I I think you
disagree that Twitter should and I think
the line is probably different place I'm
not sure honestly like I mean I I
totally get your point which is so you
know what about accidental misgendering
right like I mean I think that that
creates more even more I think the the
gendering on Twitter thing is an edge
case and I resist sometimes the instinct
to get drawn into edge cases is
representative of the whole but even
within this edge case what about
accidental misgendering I mean maybe
people have been banned for that yeah it
was yeah that may yeah yeah I don't know
yeah there was a post that went viral
where someone responded to it was a
cartoon avatar cuz it's like people do
that and they said dude come listen XYZ
a B and C and they got suspended from
misgendering for saying dude and dude
wasn't even meant to be you know gender
it was meant to be like a gender-neutral
like like you know exclamatory yeah we
actually won really fascinating thing
we're seeing with the back firing of a
lot of these laws is there now certain
you know like anti sjw types that have
asserted pronouns and their profiles to
get people banned who refuse to use it
so there it's weapon yeah I I don't know
about that and again I just I feel like
once we get into the way people misuse
policy or take advantage of that case I
I don't know that that's how I would be
making policy necessarily I think we
kind of got to the what for me the crux
of this stuff is about the legality of
it and about at a certain point do we
want social media platforms regulated as
if they were government entities because
that's that's eventually kind of the key
question right Tim like no we consider
these to be public square' entities that
should be governed in a different way we
do have some rulings already there's a
there's two there was one specifically
about Trump you can't block people
because you've created a public forum
right and so he still has some people
blocked my understanding the other was I
believe it was called like pecking at
packing ham versus North Carolina hmm
where the Supreme Court recently
unanimously ruled that the government
cannot constrain access to online online
services because it's where people get
their information do commerce find jobs
and to do so would be a restriction of
you know individual liberty you'd have
to read the exact ruling but they
essentially said social media is that
the new digital square and because of
that no law can be passed in this
country that would take someone's right
to this platform away so we're getting
there
yeah and now remember Tim there is one
thing there is a caveat there which is
passing a law that takes away someone's
access to the platform is sort of one
standard that would not preclude the
removal of specific pieces of content
even if they disproportionately affect
particular groups of people like do we
agree that these are different standards
well I
brought this ruling up specifically not
to say that they're going to do
something but at the Supreme Court's
personal view yeah is that social media
is a public square so there's there's no
there's no restrictions or on platforms
what they can or can't do yet but the
opinion of the Supreme Court is that it
is the digital public square so but I
think we're really close to getting
regulation Texas California and Florida
have already proposed them Florida's
failed Texas Texas is based on if a
platform says they're neutral but
they're not then they get then they have
to like there's a remedy for that I
don't know I think it's the AG sues them
and then with California it's a shocking
law it just says straight up any social
media site based in California can't
restrict someone for political
affiliation or the political content of
what they say post well the I mean that
would be exactly what we're talking
about that would be sort of government
saying even though this is not a
protected class according to the Civil
Rights Act or the non-discrimination you
know any of that these are additional
government provisions which I think if
you are if someone is a small government
conservative so to speak they should
probably be opposed to it right and most
of them are actually oh they're okay
yeah I don't tell you enough of them to
know so you know they are but a lot of
them are for regulation because I think
you know for the most part one thing
that you know it's it's it's a big group
of people with varying ideologies some
of them are kind of centrist
center-right and so they're gonna be
fregula or whatever and a lot of them
are gonna be laissez-faire never and I
and I am NOT laissez-faire so for me I
think we face a big challenge uh Donald
Trump is only on Twitter when he tweets
something it affects the world mm-hmm
for a private company to say you don't
you know get to stand in front of this
man or respond to him terrifies me right
because think about this
someone could tweet to Donald Trump
you're an you know an effing blah blah
blah blah blah and Twitter can be like
removed I don't like the idea of a
private company telling you I'm not
letting out the president but the issue
here is the scale if Trump were going to
a different venue yeah and I got kicked
out of one I'd be like well I'll go to
the next one and tell him you know he's
you know the c-word but if there's only
one place where he's at and the private
company is using their authority to
basically dictate what you can or can't
that terrifies me
you know I mean
think that the counter side of it is not
that I'm still Manning you know and the
anti-regulation crowd but there is a
sort of perspective that businesses
should not be regulated by the
government that they shall not be
regulated by the government beyond what
is deemed absolutely necessary and then
it just becomes a debate over whether
what you're suggesting is absolutely
necessary and then exactly a mess and I
don't know where opinion just like but
here's the thing right um let's like
forget the Conservatives yeah are you
familiar with mafic media No
so math ik Oh is gonna always gonna get
a shout-out from me they're their
anti-war leftist Pro Bernie anti
intervention but they receive I think I
think the company is half owned by RuPt
Lee which is Russia today sure
so they got suspended by Facebook and
they didn't break any rules and they
were suspended for I think like a week
and a half and it was because CNN
reached out to Facebook said hey did you
see these guys are funded by Russia
waited until Facebook took them down and
then CNN publishes this story ah gotcha
you know we found the Russian media
right another example is Twitter removed
two thousand Pro Maduro accounts I'm not
saying you should be four against Maduro
but when these things fly under the
radar I think because the left isn't as
tuned in the right is tuned in heavily
it's like Donald I don't know that I
would like to see evidence for the
assertion about who's tuned in because I
think that you know making any kind of
broad claim like that I would want to be
super clear on on where that that's
coming from sometimes people say
attention to something and they don't
comment so you know I think there's
different ways to measure right but I
think that even though is where the
accounts removed because they were Pro
Maduro if so I mean again I don't even
think there's anything illegal about
that we can art we can argue it should
be illegal right which is what you and I
talking about exactly it's not currently
illegal what the content of the of the
messages were because it's possible I
just don't know enough about that
according their incident you know
Twitter referred to it I believe and
again I google it they said something
like it was interference or governmental
interference or something and they they
work I believe they were quoted as
saying though they didn't have direct
evidence something like that I don't I
don't know the full details I just know
that
what I end up seeing is the anti-war
left people who essentially oppose the
the machine in various capacities are
excised excuse me
and you know it's gonna happen that
they're gonna CNN's already laying the
stones against Bernie you know what I
mean they they they had all those people
to CNN who are working for these
lobbying groups you don't like the idea
of the of the of the the massive machine
restricting access to the new public
square it may be that I'm in front of
the market I'm at very tech you know
technological individual I was in the a
community so I think maybe the things
I'm seeing are more alarming to me
because I'm like watching them develop
but it'll maybe hit the mainstream but
rest assured you know they're gonna ban
everybody arbitrarily if they have the
power to ban everybody arbitrarily and
that includes somebody who wants to call
Donald Trump the c-word you know that
that maybe I'm curious I mean the the
type of regulation you're describing
that would apply to Twitter or Facebook
for example should it be also applied
equally to the content on web sites like
Reddit and 4chan so well the different
sites and this is the new I know that
they're different sites yeah so I just
mean to say like the structure of the
algorithm and how they function is
different yes and there's a serious
challenge because I'll say this too I
believe that if right now the US
government said Supreme Court unanimous
Twitter can no longer remove people for
hate speech or whatever Twitter would
probably like like just fall apart okay
it's gonna get it's gonna get overrun by
the nastiest insanity you can't do
anything about it but I suppose they
might also roll out you know better
moderation tools where people can
control what it is that they're seeing I
mean I think they would manage I don't
think it would be the end of Twitter no
I mean like if they weren't allowed to
moderate based on legal speech right
right you know the idea the idea would
be there might be abandonment because it
becomes such a horrible experience for a
lot of users but I think they draw
duration tools that users can use for
themselves
oh yeah yeah well then maybe I mean that
isn't that a good thing oh those tools
are good no matter what yeah I have
thousands of gentle muted but my
question is I know that reddit can I
know read it in 14 or different websites
but what I'm saying is would you apply
the same type of government intervention
regulation to them um it depends on what
the govern is because it might have to
do with certain technological aspects so
and again let me try and clarify twitter
is a reverse
illogical system with a default
algorithmic system algorithmic versus
reverse chronological is gonna have
entirely different laws so Twitter's
algorithm chooses who to put in front of
you all right so that you can't regulate
who they're promoting reverse
chronological you can say it's got to be
this way
I mean don't you have I'm trying to
remember you know I'm spending less and
less time on Twitter but on my Twitter
app I have the option of seeing the sort
of what's called like the cute you know
the curated feed but I can press a
button telling it that I don't want it
to make judgments like show me
low-quality tweets show me everything so
right right maybe that's not a hundred
percent but it seems like there's
elements of both in on on Twitter no
you're right you can easily switch
between the two right so this so the
issue would be like I think YouTube's an
easier example when you go to
youtube.com it shows you fifteen videos
you might have a thousand subscriptions
sure so YouTube has to choose who you're
gonna see that's promotion
I don't think YouTube's under any
obligation to promote your content okay
in terms of your subscription tab
however it should notify you that the
person you're following has a new video
and you can choose to click it and go to
their channel so algorithmic versus
reverse chronological very different if
I say I follow you and I want to see
your tweet what happens and that's how
the system works right and we put a
regulation in place it would be specific
to that feed which is part of the
challenge yeah but again so I mean on
Reddit you can hit the new feed which
will show you reverse chronological or
you can hit the hot feed which is a sort
of popularity based algorithm so again
it seems like the difference you're
pointing out that is making you fall
short of saying Reddit and 4chan should
be regulated the same way is not really
that much of a difference so I mean if
you don't think Reddit and 4chan should
be regulated the same way that's a
totally legitimate position to take I
would just want to know that I think in
terms of user jet-like so so right it
isn't an algorithm what what gets
uploaded is based on what the community
chooses to push forward yes so there are
always questions as to whether that is a
complete representation of what the
community is voting for or whether
reddit is influencing it but in theory
that's what it is okay I mean if people
don't vote you know what do you do like
we want to encourage them to vote if
they don't that's what they get in fact
I believe it's it's called the one
that 1% of users on reddit are the ones
making the content go to the top sure I
need not just absorb it I mean I think
that's the same on Twitter though
because most people don't like reply or
retweet tweets that they read right it's
true yeah you're right I I got to be
honest though man I really you know I
can see these problems I don't think I'm
solving but I do feel I don't know I I'm
just wondering like if there's something
that you think is uniquely different
where you don't want 4chan and reddit
subjected to whatever regulation you do
favor later and also regulation want to
be specific based on technology but they
should all be under the same constraints
right okay yeah I got no special
privileges for anybody but but but again
acknowledging you know 4chan isn't an
algorithmic system it's just based on
when you comment it moves to the top so
the difference I'm trying to make I
guess is that YouTube chooses the
winners and losers and so does Facebook
you can't regulate that you like
Facebook is under no obligation to
promote me to anyone right if I have a
page you can go to it if you want to
right so it's different it's tough I
don't know
unless someone chooses we're first
chronological feed I don't know fair
enough fair enough
okay well listen I mean I don't I don't
do these like for our streams where we
continue eating a dead horse what I like
to do is this is a really good initial
conversation I think my audience and I
now have a better sense of sort of where
you stand and I want to think more about
these issues but I think that this has
been very very interesting and one of
the you know I mean politic political
differences aside because we have them I
hate doing this stuff where I pretend
like it's all about the marketplace of
ideas and every idea deserves the exact
same amount of time not for any of that
[ __ ] as I agree but I do think that
if we can have actual productive
conversations about important issues
even if we have political disagreements
that that's still a good thing and
hopefully the audience agrees with that
oh hell yeah this is what we need to be
doing man and I want to point out that
what you when you when the point you
made about it's the idea not the
identity is is extremely important
particularly for me and I think for the
conversation because I think that is
being lost right the idea that Twitter
we need to separate the ideas from
identity right I think we do I think we
yeah yeah that's fascinating actually
I'm gonna think so if everybody who's
watching on my channel stick around
because I there's a million super chats
that I want to get to I may even open up
the phone lines and all of this stuff
but Tim we should do this again maybe on
a different topic maybe on this topic
maybe we bring in somebody else I mean
who knows but I think that this has been
this has been extraordinarily useful if
if if not the most we haven't solved
these problems but at least we've
identified where we see the problems
existing let me let me let me just give
you like my final take on you know this
is one small piece of a bigger argument
that I'm concerned about its Amazon is
taking over commerce
PayPal is taking over transactions like
Twitter Facebook Google are taking over
like news media in this country is dying
partly because Google and Facebook have
monopolized advertising revenue so
they're being strangled we like we got
to do something about these monopolies
whatever whatever form that takes like
I'm game to have that conversation yeah
I mean antitrust is once again becoming
a major major issue I know Elizabeth
Warren's been talking about it Bernie a
little bit but I it's you're not hearing
that much and part of it is because
Democrats and Republicans both are
funded by a lot of these same companies
that have a vested interest in
suppressing competition that's the
bottom line right I I like seeing the
Republicans called the Koch brothers now
for two reasons
their open borders policy and their
refusing to get behind free speech it
makes you wonder right absolutely
absolutely and we've been following that
all right Tim I'm gonna let you go on
skype but let's touch base after I'll
let you get to it to your stream I'm
gonna talk to some of your viewers and I
really appreciate you being on with me
today no I appreciate you too man
appreciate it
I always recommend you because I think
you do a good job thank you all right
take care Tim we'll talk soon yes
all right so we'll close out there I'm
also on Tim's channel which I'm going to
close out okay there we go
and let me get this other computer shut
down because we've got I mean it's just
like computers on computers on computers
here to make this all happen okay if
people okay first and foremost there
have been people signing up for
memberships just like crazy while this
was all going on so I'm glad that people
have appreciate
what we've been doing and let me say
thanks to some of these people if you
are interested in me opening the phone
lines like right now and hearing from
you about how you think this all went if
we get 10 new members I'll open up the
phone lines ok memberships are really
easy to get takes one minute on my
website it's the primary funding source
for what I do all of these extra streams
and stuff we've been doing are directly
funded by memberships just pick up a
membership david pakman.com slash
membership the normal prices are really
really affordable even better the coupon
code this is 20/20 will save you 40% off
of any membership and even more
importantly if you want a membership for
25 bucks for the entire year it's 2
bucks a month ok it's 2 bucks a month if
you want a membership for just 25 bucks
select the $60 yearly membership apply
the coupon code save 35 that membership
will drop to just 25 bucks for the
entire year I'll say your name and thank
you for signing up and it's really I
mean it's you by the way this actually
wasn't even gonna get into this but
there is a situation going on with
YouTube ad revenue that's affecting me
Sam cedar The Young Turks Kyle kolinsky
I don't know if they've been talking
about it but it's it's an issue that
YouTube's got to get fixed which maybe
I'll talk about on the show tomorrow but
in any case membership is how we're
funded pays for staff salaries pays for
the equipment the studio all of this
stuff and I will gladly take some phone
calls if 10 people sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership there are so
many super chats i'm gonna just try to
take an overview of what's been said
because there is just so much here
questions about trade wars somebody sent
500 Swedish kronor asking me to touch my
hair there you go very very soft and
pliable completely pliable in case
anybody's worried about that Nabil
Kaveri says Tim got busted and that edgy
Dave Rubin is a way to describe him pack
God can fall asleep and still expose
this hack that's not very nice beanie is
cheaper than to pay very efficient
as aggressive shout-out to Sean rankling
Tim when will you debate destiny tim
pools not used to being called out holy
[ __ ] I wish I I was just focusing on the
conversation I had no idea that this
much Tim Poole hate was going going it
here keep up the great work big fan of
both David and Tim hope you can find
common ground do more drawing on
Instagram Tim help you need help keeping
your thoughts together while Tim's gone
affirmative action only helps white
people uh Tim Poole lied about no-go
zones I don't know anything about that
Tim and his lackeys are crybabies if you
guys made love who would be on top do
you think the current problem of tech
base monopolies is similar to the rail
monopolies could this current problem be
solved in the same way as his cabinet
took care of the railroad monopolies in
of the infant 20th century his cabinet
whose whose cabinet I'm not sure I fully
understand that what about porn or spam
comments on Twitter if it was government
regulated I mean that's a that's an open
question I don't know I don't that's why
I'm so sort of not skeptical because I'm
not skeptical I think it is necessary to
some degree but that's why I'm so
careful I think I would say about
exactly how these regulations would work
and what the unintended consequences
would be because I do think that it
opens pretty dangerous pretty dangerous
territory the memes of destruction says
we need less yelling and more
conversations like this thank you i I
appreciate that and I hope that it was
enjoyable to people okay let me say
thanks to a few people
TJ Russell jr. has signed up and is a
new member that's new member number one
of the evening Michael Woods has signed
up using the coupon code this is 20/20
that's new member number two of the
evening and Michael McPherson has signed
up
and that is new member number three of
the evening so if people want me to open
up the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty seven
more members and I'll do that as I've
said before membership is really cheap
really really cheap I know that for a
lot of people in our audience because
they let me know money is tight and
that's okay I still I'm doing the show
for you for everybody it doesn't matter
but for the people in the audience who
can't afford even just two bucks a month
and that is most of the people in the
audience that that actually makes us
totally independent of needing huge
corporate advertisers it makes us
independent of all sorts of other
fluctuations and that's why I talk about
membership and why it's so important a
new feature by the way funded by
membership is that we have effective
yesterday we have started properly
captioning subtitling all of our YouTube
videos not the live streams but all of
our daily clips for people who are both
hard-of-hearing or just like to read
along with the show that's something
that's funded directly by membership
fees we also did a technical upgrade to
the program we're not the live streams
but the uploaded clips are in higher
resolution and better audio quality
which I know people who are watching on
anything bigger than like a 20-inch
monitor are already appreciating so a
lot of continued exciting developments
all funded by membership rapid is a new
YouTube channel member that's new member
number four of the evening and Vegas
Bushido is new member number five of the
evening so we're halfway there in pretty
short order and again I don't have
unlimited time tonight but if people
want me to take some phone calls I will
gladly do it if we get five more members
let me see so I want to look at a couple
places I had no idea people were
reacting so aggressively to Tim let me
first look at the regular chat just to
see what things are looking like in
terms of people
Tim's continuing to think and talk about
the conversation on a stream while David
is pushing pitching memberships well go
over to Tim pools stream that no problem
whatsoever is the TV behind me sideways
yes it is someone attacked your website
David Pakman is that true let me take a
look at that I hope that's not true I'm
gonna look at it on my phone someone
attacked my website wouldn't be the
first time that that's happened yeah it
does seem is the website down it does
appear to be down
that is interesting I wonder what's
going on might be some kind of DDoS
attack again or something like that
people are calling Tim's a fascist to
him has had twice as many viewers as
David yeah I rarely stream and I think
he's been promoting it a lot longer it
is interesting that the web site does
seem to be down which is going to make
it difficult for people to sign up and
if that's the case I may need to just go
and deal with that people saying that
it's not loading very very strange yeah
all right I'm gonna have to go deal with
that because if it is a DDoS attack I've
got to go and get our web person on
right away so a lovely way to wrap up a
very respectful conversation with Tim
Poole that does it for the stream I will
probably do a stream tomorrow and we'll
have more time to do all sorts of
different stuff